Guys, it is time for
"Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Good names, bad names ♪
♪ Great names, yes ♪
[ Whistling and applause ]
First up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mumbles ]
-Give it a try.
-Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Clucking as a ticking clock ]
-Time's running out, Gramps.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh! Oh!
Hey! Come on.
-Two weeks goes fast.
[ Applause continues ]
After that, we have
Beautiful Mistakes...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, yes! Oh, yeah!
Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Only 5 seconds.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Next up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
[ Cheering ]
Next up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Coughs ]
-Lot of coughing.
Lot of coughing.
After that, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitating revving engine ]
-[Both] Bad Habits.
-And, finally, we have...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."